je n'arrive toujours pas à croire qu'ils
aient changé la date de leur mariage à
la dernière on trouvera quand même un
moyen de célébrer son anniversaire je
crois que je fais vieille alors tu es
superbe tué six
[Musique]
talibans
tiens au nom merci non elle boit pas
d'alcool elle en a jamais vu dit marie
avec un homme qui a d'un bois
isaac vient au mariage dans l'embauché
mon ex petit ami pour démolir notre
maison familiale ça sonne plutôt mal
quand tu le dis comme ça
[Musique]
allons-y
t'entends pas ou quoi j'arrêtais pas te
crier de ralentir chute des données liam
quasthoff de boire maintenant
je me sens mal priam il n'a pas lé
canadien au moins ils ont la passion
clémence ne veut plus que tu viennes en
mariage moi je sens que ton énergie et
auxi et je veux pas de ça prenne mois
pour le jour le plus important de ma vie
et toi ya une énergie toxiques machine
tu es méchante il peut tout contrôler
totalement et butt
[Rires]
tu es toujours si belle non ce n'est pas
vrai il a
passé la soirée avec ton petit ami me
suis perdu dans cette fausse réalité
tous les justes pour tyr jeunes et nous
qu'est ce qu'il ya de si génial à être
jeune en fait tu fais des choses
stupides et tu prend de mauvaises
décisions
[Musique]
mon frère a toujours eu des goûts très
difficile et très raffiné alors je suis
sûr que tu es une personne merveilleuse
et j'ai vraiment hâte m
au ministère
je vais remettre tout en place c'est pas
dangereux
c'est de faire du mal je suis vraiment
et ne leva et sortir